bon oui mais beaucoup de pétards voulait
yam et à certains médias par rapport à
gérard mieux non moi je n'ai jamais bu
fumé en tout cas je suis jamais cessé
mais avec nan sérieusement certains
membres oui même si avec d'ailleurs des
amendes maintenant ouais pour en parler
avec lui on accueille un député le
député de l'essonne
voici nicolas dupont aignan mesdames p 6
dupont-aignan député ump de l'essonne
énarque comme quoi pas sourire l'ajout
sonné les émissions des énarques caire
qui savent tout et rien d'autre voilà
cette année n'a serrar qui les énerve
sur ce plateau on est très très contents
regardez bien les enfants c'est un vrai
narc alors la nouveauté cette semaine
tout le monde en parle c'est donc les
amendes pour usage de cannabis
alors sarkozy nous avait déjà fait les
amendes pour mendicité l'interdiction de
séjourner dans les halls d'immeuble
c'est qu'il ya des mecs compris trois
mois fermes pris ce qu'ils étaient dans
un hall d'immeuble
oui dira mot oui et tout le monde oublie
de dire vous oubliez de dire que dans
les halls d'immeuble parfois c'est
jusqu'à 5 heures du matin que les gens
ne peuvent pas dormir on à ma
circonscription dans ma ville j'ai des
expériences et à un moment il faut vite
agir quand toute une cage d'escalier
n'en peut plus qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça
faisait des années que ça dure est donc
à mende sur la mendicité les halls
d'immeuble les flash ball a joué le
football
et puis les [ __ ] en taule pour éviter
qu'elle soit dans le cese ça fait sale
comme ça sur les trottoirs donc on
l'aimé on l'aimé en taule est ce que
toutes ces mesures finalement n'était
pas déjà dans le code pénal est ce que
ça méritait des lois supplémentaires
ce qu'il faut savoir sur les halls
d'immeuble ou lady un instant moi dans
ma circonscription dans ma ville il ya
des gens ils peuvent pas dormir ça fait
des mois que ça dure
qu'est ce qu'on fait il y avait pas de
2,2 règles qui permettait à la police de
faire cesser non pas la présence d'un
hall d'immeuble mais l'abus la du
manifeste ou dans un quartier vous n'en
pouvez plus vous croyez pas que c'est
arbitraire ce jardin la station c'est
arbitraire moi je peut vous emmener un
endroit dans la ou je vais vous emmener
un endroit sombre les gens ils en
venaient aux mains et à jour un type et
il n'en pouvait plus parce qu'il a
peut-être le droit au sommeil ils
bossent si la loire le matin de partir
au travail sans être emmerdé par des
gens qui lui bloquent l'accès ctce où
vous aviez des types en bas de chez moi
qui parle pas du les peurs qu'elle va
pitbull en liberté et qui nous faisait
peur en permanence
il ya un moment ça suffit pour pas perdu
au port vauban par le prix de l'eau
facile c'est trop facile de l'extérieur
de prendre une mesure et de dire vous
voyez vous pouvez plus stationner cinq
minutes dans un hall d'immeuble on n'en
est pas là sachez vraiment qu'on n'est
pas là on en est action action dans un
endroit où les gens pourraient aller
pour éviter dans les halls d'immeuble il
faut faire des maisons de quartier
quartier on a fait des lieux et ça se
passe très bien
simplement il y a dans un quartier 10
personnes ou quatre qui empêche
saint-cloud dix mille personnes de vivre
et cela il y en a marre c'est tout alors
pas d'abus faut pas non plus et excessif
mais il faut se donner les moyens
juridiques d'intervenir parce qu'on
appelait la police
la police dit moi j'ai pas le droit
d'intervenir donc c'est se donner
simplement le moyen d'intervenir pour
éviter les abus
mais est ce que toutes ces mesures
répressives n'était pas déjà dans le
code pénal
non justement les policiers n'avaient
pas les moyens d'agir
c'est pareil pour le racolage actif
passif pascal reinhart
ce suivi lui plus énarque parce que
einat 34 ans maire de yerres c'est pas
l'ena qui m'a formé chez besson c'est
très difficile de dialoguer ne pas
relayer il ya cette espèce de
déformation comme ça de l'homme
politique qui continue de parler malgré
l'intervention surtout cette
intervention est un mulet dérange un
tout petit peu donc on continue sa
phrase
mais c'est une technique c'est pas mal
et c'est aussi on va là on va tomber
d'accord existait déjà savoir que le
tapage nocturne problèmes de tapage
nocturne
c'est le problème vous aviez enfin je
vais pas me répéter mais dans des halls
d'immeuble une femme est venue voir le
peux pas rentrer chez elle pourquoi est
ce qu'on a le droit de laisser des
personnes et roriz et une autre médaille
d'or mais tous les jours j'en avais tous
les jours enfin on peut intervenir mais
aller voir les gens ils sont rarement
est-ce qu'ils sont syndiqués minimes aux
règles mais regarde on en est loin et
l'amener on n'en est pas là encore
jean petit branle dans l'analyse des
données de gens tous les jours il ya des
zones à zhang des jeunes qui sauf qu'il
faudrait étudier qui veulent rentrer en
boîte et à qui on refuse un très bon
mais il ya des genres et à 10 pour la
première fois avec nicolas sarkozy va se
faire des câlins et st-gall et et la loi
elle doit être la même pour tous mais à
quoi ça sert d'avoir des lois jamais
appliquée pareil pour le jeune qui se
fait refuser l'entrée roulant boj doit
pareil pour le jeune par deux fois je il
se fait refuser l'embauché sur la
toiture on m'a dit non je suis mal barré
mais jma années quand vient le voir mais
je continue la loi doit être la même
pour tout ce qui est insupportable c'est
quand on a des lois qui ne sont pas
respectées à quoi ça sert il ya deux
semaines un membre du groupe aux gens le
pendant 48 heures pour un accident
fictif et lors de la déposition le
policier qui lui dit en arabe c'est
tenir un stylo ça c'est la réalité
mais pareil et bassiste mais qu'un titre
sur des jeux ne sommes pas condamnés
alors pour dire un truc comme ça et
qu'il ya une crise et par trois
personnes en sang qui discute ainsi
maintenant la plus drôle être devant
demain chez soi mais en réalité la
protège encore plus on de traverse et
des soins des jeunes comme ça
à marseille nice ou frites chez denise
tu sais qu'on vivait dans la rue avant
l'apparition de la télévision à gênés
quand six ans était assis sur des
chaises de sang à l'époque il y avait
moins de pitbull certains venir des
chiens allez vous disiez nicolas dupont
aignan il ya beaucoup de lois qui sont
pas beaucoup de mails pour dire non et
notamment la loi de 70 sur les sur la
drogue quoi qui effectivement né n'est
pas appliquée alors maintenant il ya un
nouveau truc qui vient de sortir
donc ces amendes pour usage de cannabis
avec confiscation confiscation du
portable et confiscation du scooter
attendait ça c'est pas décidé en
revanche vous savez très bien qu'il y
avait une loi de 70 qui prévoyait une
peine de prison pour usage de cannabis
un cas ce qu'a dit nicolas sarkozy sait
que c'était absurde avoir une loi qui
avait une peine excessive n'étaient pas
appliquées alors de deux choses l'une où
on dépénalise et on dit aux français
vous fumer du cannabis comme vous voulez
où on applique une loi avec une mesure
adaptées qu'est ce que la mesure adaptée
c'est une sanction de contraventions qui
permettra de rappeler l'interdît est ce
que c'est normal que dans notre pays on
soit le premier consommateur pour les 16
ans de cannabis est le seul problème des
gens qui est très dessin problèmes des
gens donc pas rentré ça c'est des
problèmes des gens qui parlent des plus
tard c'est que eux n'ont jamais fumé
c'est un c'est un immense problème c'est
qu'au fond c'est comme si on se mettait
à parler de la grossesse à temps les
champions
nicolas sérieusement soit il ya une
chose moi que je comprends pas vous êtes
peut-être m'expliquer l'alcool est en
vente libre du cannabis n'est pas
énormément depuis dallas ont testé
énormément justement l'alcool et le
cannabis ont testé voir à la fin sur le
plateau le premier qui vomit qui peut
conduire
voilà sérieux
ils réellement sur l'europe on est
capable en europe de s'aligner sur des
choses est vraiment sur des projets qui
ont tout tout ça très au pognon pourquoi
on n'arrive pas à s'aligner avec
d'autres pays qui ont des trucs
intéressants sur les problèmes de
dépénalisation ou sur des problèmes de
rythmes scolaires
la dépénalisation dans certains pays le
prépare les finir hollande
catastrophique et la hollande de revenir
dessus
pour une raison simple c'est que s'il
n'y a pas un interdit là dessus la
plupart des jeunes vont fumer du
cannabis à des conséquences quand un
jeune est déscolarisé va plus à l'école
parce qu'ils fument du cannabis à 7
heures du matin il ya deux solutions
soit la société bien pensante qui fument
sont joints dans son bel appartement
parisien s'en fout soit on se dit c'est
interdit parce qu'on rappelle interdit
aux parents rappelle interdit aux jeunes
et on se pose peut-être la question de
savoir pourquoi un jeune de 15 ans
fument en tant que canadiens si vous
étiez un land d'autres discutent d'abord
je ne pense pas que vous soyez un
politique et vous ne pourriez pas tenir
ce discours qui paraît totalement
obsolète en hollande où ils sont en mise
en sommeil au parler franc c'est bien si
on n'a pas envie d'être dans un lieu
unique les le résultat est
catastrophique en blanc et vous le savez
bien même le gouvernement hollandais
fait son chemin dans les canalisations
vous savez quand hollande en s'adressant
gens qui sont cette fois plus en jouant
les joints très dangereux le maire
d'angers raison de ce qu'on va laisser
on est bien alors ça veut dire qu'on est
spectateur d'une société on s'en fout on
les laisse on s'en fout moi je suis
désolé on est même politique on est élu
on a un devoir de dire ce qui est
dangereux ce qui est pas dangereux et du
cannabis vous savez bien que ça modifie
le comportement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui je regardais avant de
venir
jeulin de la santé publique vous avez à
peu près 20% des accidents de voitures
qui sont liées usage de cannabis et
d'alcool
c'est d'abord nié la vitesse et l'alcool
la vitesse en vol le temps n'importe
quoi et des décès nuance beaucoup
je pose une question vous allez dans
n'importe quel village de france
la rue principale de 400 m il ya six
barres moi j'ai perdu six amis par
l'alcool en un an
venez pas me dire que même seulement la
différence c'est que l'alcool ça fait
partie du patrimoine et la culture
trois nourrices et la culture et essar
n'a jamais aussi sévère encore dupont
n'a jamais été aussi sévère sur les
contrôles routiers le gouvernement n'a
jamais été aussi sévère pour la première
fois il ya 3000 membres
il ya 3000 morts de moins sur la route
il faut savoir qu'en france il ya des
millions de gens qui fument qui s'est
passé dans les moeurs
que tu le veuilles ou non ça fait partie
de la culture le pétard voilà au tir la
douane de prison parce que c'était
absurde
en revanche de signifier l'interdît le
fait que les mineurs ne doivent pas
consommer ce genre de produits je ne
vois pas en quoi c'est choquant et
convient de retrait à l'assemblée
nationale interdiction du tabac aux
mineurs et on a eu raison
non al en dessous de 16 ans on vient à
l'interdît on va avancer un petit peu
dernière question tiens c'est juste pour
dire que moi moi je ne fume pas d'eau
chaude d'autant mieux placé pour en
parler parce que ça apporterait une
spéciale par contre le traitement que
vous faites à l'alcool et la cigarette
sur laquelle vous prélever des taxes
énormes et pour pourquoi pourquoi ne pas
aligner tout simplement ses produits si
vous en pénaliser on vous dit vous
pénaliser tout si vous entendez pénalité
vous avez un discours ou qui est ultra
paternaliste mais vous comprenez qu'un
jeune de 16 ans il est pas envie qu'on
lui dise ne fais pas ci ne fait pas ça
le pétard est interdit il faut éviter sa
généralisation il faut lutter contre les
trafics impôts éviter que les mineurs
rentrent dans un engrenage et c'est
notre rôle de définir cette intervention
bien alors il ya le prix les amendes or
là c'est marrant parce qu'il ya
différentes écoles tout énervé comme
perben tout est là c'est 1500 euros ce
qui fait quand même 10 - la
contravention de 5e classe qui
permettrait comme les excès de vitesse
quand vous avez dit déjà quelque chose
quand vous avez 10 amende successives
c'est à dire surtout pour les
récidivistes de transformer ça en délit
ensuite et puis un autre thèse n'a pas
tranché 1500 euros ça c'est perben et
puis un matin y suit la canicule
lui c'est 135 euros ça fait mille balles
mais actuellement c'est une peine de
prison qui n'est pas appliquée qu'est ce
qu'on dit où on dépénalise et on arrête
toutes les amendes ont dit strictement
que c'est interdit et à ce moment là
c'est normal notamment pour les mineurs
que l'on sanctionne usage de cannabis
qui s'accompagne parfois aussi de dim
vous le savez très bien même ça je pense
pas que ça avait très bien entre entre
nous sur du vent je voyais pas soyez
joyeux
je suis né dans une cité où je ne sais
que les gars de la drogue 9,4 ce mois
plus que vous êtes qu'est ce que nous
est toujours facile la vie dit carrément
était tombée les jeunes alors et non
mais vous pensez que c'est lors ce
trafic
nicolas ça c'est l'effet du pétard mais
alors permis sans dire que les gens
seront il est propre et à enfin en
buvant du whisky bravo s'il fait réussi
le mélange non alors donc monsieur
raffarin donnera la réponse sur le prix
des amendes
demain soir sur m6 à punition qui
s'appelle en interne est juste en tout
cas de le dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
d'amendé pour le lexomil le valium le
tranxène ça va déjà on peut sans mettre
balle à la lampe de 5 et bien et le vin
rouge papier l'état revient alors le
plus drôle
nicolas le plus drôle c'est que ce
caporalisme qu'on vous reproche un petit
peu là vous en êtes victimes au sein de
votre propre parti qui s'appelle l'ump
donc car messieurs chirac et raffarin
ont refusé la constitution de courant à
l'intérieur de l'ump ce qui était prévu
d'après les statuts du parti il rejoint
départ on m'a fatigué votre courant va
vous gaulliste souverainiste on peut
dire ne peut pas s'exprimer
ça veut dire quoi je veux dire que les
gens qui ont fait confiance à monsieur
juppé pour l'ump sont cocus aujourd'hui
et c'est ce que chez vous le premier bah
oui oui moi je suis non parce que on
peut s'exprimer c'est pas ça simplement
la direction du parti refusent un
congrès où on vote sur des points c'est
à dire que mois de novembre il était
prévu qu'on déposé un texte moi je vais
préparer un terrain et on vote dessus et
a dit m
baisse des impôts entraîna turquie en
europe etc où on botte et les instances
du parti ont décidé qu'il fallait
repousser ça et c'est vrai que j'ai
critiqué en disant oui on en revient aux
moeurs des années 60
oui une blonde des novillos comme on
disait à l'époque du général de gaulle à
ça on n'a pas rénové la vie politique
avec l'ump pour refaire un parti qui
n'écoutent pas sa base théorique et
amine dans la question nicolas dupont
aignan non non moi jdis que le dire je
trouve que ses généraux il ya un manque
de règles non mais
c'est dans le rôle de méchant non non je
n'étais pas du tout non pas du tout non
je vous laisse il a le droit d aller